of
Allah the pleasure of
Allah oh you believe read the
Quran every night of
[Music]
Ramadan night of
Ramadan welcome oh
[Music]
Ramadan it is
dear brothers and sisters in Islam and
Humanity may peace mercy and blessings
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
be on all of
you welcome to the show Ramadan a date
with Dr
Zakia I am your host Yousef Chambers and
today we will be discussing the topic
benefits of
fasting Dr zakya once again I greet you
with
salams the benefits of fasting Dr
zakya in the previous
episode we discussed the objectives of
fasting and within the objectives of
fasting we mentioned the spiritual
religious
benefits are there any other benefits
that you need to tell the audience about
alul
as far as benefits besides religious and
spiritual benefits there are various
benefits of fasting and as you rightly
mentioned in the last interview
discussed about religious and spiritual
there are other benefits which can be
categorized into three different
categories physical benefits of fasting
there are psychological benefits of
fasting as well as there are social
benefits of fasting I see
let's move on to the first category the
physical benefits what exactly are the
physical benefits of
fasting since fasting mainly involves in
abstaining from food drink and sex from
dawn up to
sunset here we realize that the stomach
is the main organ of the body which has
the maximum diseases maximum ailments
that's why I beloved Prophet M wasallam
said it's mentioned in MA Vol number
four Hadith number 3349 AB Prophet
said that there is nothing better that a
son of Adam can
fill in the container with more evils
than the stomach it is
sufficient for a man to be on his feet
with a few muscles but if he has to eat
more he can divide the stomach into
three parts one third for the food one3
for the drink and one3 for his breath or
one3 for the air so what we realize that
the maximum diseases originate in the
stomach because it's house for
bacteria
and the food that we eat it enters the
stomach from the stomach it gets
digested goes into the intestinal tract
then the food nutrients enter the
bloodstream and then goes to almost all
the different organs of the body and we
realize that the stomach is working
continuously throughout the life it
never gets any
rest when we
fast this stomach which is a very
delicate organ though it's very delicate
it is a very complicated organ it's
delicate at the same time it's very
important it keeps on working throughout
the
day this organ while we fast when no
food enters for several hours it gets
rest and the toxins that are there in
the body
they are removed they are purged out so
fasting is a very good way that
physically it's beneficial for the body
it removes all the toxins and it helps
in various
diseases what about the psychological
impacts upon the human
psyche regarding fasting I think that's
very important as far as the
psychological Dimension is concerned
fasting helps in patients for bance and
perseverance it helps a person to
increase his
self-control
his
selfworth it helps him to increase the
self reflexivity also the self trining
and discipline is
improved the main psychological benefit
of fasting is the increase in patience
and
perseverance and it can make a person
who says I cannot do it can make him say
I can do and fasting helps in the
conditioning of the heart body mind and
soul it improves the overall
dimension of the human
being and fasting is a sort of training
it even helps in behavioral change and
changing a behavior is very difficult a
person who's used to a particular be
very difficult it is as we say that the
best type of jihad is
Jihad that is is striving against your
own soul so to change the habits is one
of the thing which is most difficult
which fasting can do and since Jihad
that is going in the battlefield is of
utmost important and required if you
cannot do Jihad if you cannot strive
against your own soul how can you strive
against the enemy so therefore fasting
helps in that Dimension that's the
reason fasting was made F before Jihad
fasting was made F 15 years after
prophet in the second hij and next year
one year later Jihad was made first so
Allah subhana tala first wanted to train
and make the Muslims fit
psychologically with the help of fasting
and then theal part was made first so
psychologically it's very helpful and
normally a human being he eats three
meals in a day in a week about 21 meals
now that is changed
that behavior pattern of eating is
changed to two meals light meal late in
the evening or early night and Before
Dawn so the whole pattern is changed and
this helps in various psychological
aspects the training and today
psychology tell us that if you can
control your hunger you can control
almost all your
desires actually from the psychological
aspect myself just to add something
there um it was the fasting in the last
week and a half of Ramadan which changed
it for me it changed my mind totally
alhamdulillah and that's what actually
led me to taking the shahada
alhamdulillah basically alhamdulillah
that's why I mentioned psychological
aspects very important on to the next
question regarding the social impact of
fasting um there any specific areas that
you can shed light on for a as far as
the social impact is concerned in
fasting the person
realizes about the other human beings
who are poor who don't have food who
don't have shelter and it makes us
realize that how does it feel when a
person is hungry many of us who are rich
who have no problem of eating food when
we fast we realize how does it feel when
a person is hungry so our love and our
care for the poor people
increases and furthermore even we
realize the boundaries of Allah subhana
tala how many times do we really thank
Allah subhana wa taala for the food he
has given us for the water imagine the
air that we get that we breathe how many
times do we thank Allah for that so the
food the water which Allah provides us
the rich people hardly their mind goes
towards it but while fasting they
realize that it helps them to care for
the poor people it also helps them in
being generous with the other human
beings in sharing with other human
beings it also helps in forgiving other
people's fault so fasting helps to
society in various ways and furthermore
our beloved Prophet M wasallam said it's
mentioned
in alj Vol number one Hadith number 896
the Beloved Prophet said that if you
have mercy on those on the earth then
those who are in the heaven they will
have mercy on you that means if you're
merciful to the other human beings Allah
subhana wa ta'ala will have mercy on you
so this fasting it helps us in building
the society better it helps us in being
generous helps us in being loving in
caring with the other human beings and
besides not only the poor people it
helps us in being good with all the
human beings it helps us in being good
with the family helps us in being good
with society and many of times we don't
realize that we don't give enough time
to our family especially in the Western
World at least in fasting you with your
family twice and people make it a point
that in fasting at least they should do
the with the family and at least break
the fast with the family so at least
they are with the family twice in the
day so the bonding in the family
increases the the family get together
the parents get more closer to the
children especially in the western world
where this
neglected as far as the society is
concerned it is very helpful ful in
getting the together we many a time go
to our neighbors during ifar we call our
friends call our neighbors and the
Beloved Prophet M wasallam said it's
mentioned in say Muslim number three
Hadith number 5379 the prophet said
whenever you are invited do not refuse
so people invite each other during ifar
during the month of Ramadan so it helps
in getting the human beings closer to
one another whether it be the neighbors
whether it be the society at large and
it's also a very good time for
selfimprovement as well as doing isah
and da you meet people in the mosque
many people who don't go to the mosque
every month of come to Mosk we meet them
we can chat with them we go
fori and this is the time we can do
Islam we can da to the non-muslim and as
you rightly said Ramadan was the month
the time which change your heart and
Allah gave you this is very important
and that's why the Beloved Prophet wasam
said mentioned
in Hadith number 1924 that Allah bestows
his Mercy on
those who themselves show Mercy to
others again a prophet says and he
continues in this
Hadith that if you show Mercy to those
on Earth those in the heaven will show
Mercy to you so fasting helps in
building up the society and getting
people closer to one
another dear brothers and sisters
inshallah we'll meet soon after a short
break dear brothers and sisters in Islam
and Humanity asalamu alaykum welcome
back to the show Ramadan date with Dr
zakya I'm your host Yousef Chambers and
today we are discussing the benefits of
fasting Dr Zakia let's move on to the
next question I want to come back to um
some of the points you were mentioning
under the physical uh changes and uh
benefits of the fast what are the
medical implications of fasting there
are innumerable medical benefits When a
person fast I'll just mention a few of
them it organizes the heartbeat and
relaxes it
it
reduces the pressure on the heart
arteries and it reduces the fat the
cholesterol as well as the acids it
releases the pressure on the liver
fasting also decreases the secretion of
the digestive glands which normally
causes aler there less chances of having
kidney stones in a % fast fasting is
also helpful in noninsulin dependent
diabetes and fasting is also helpful
inducing the
weight fasting as a whole it is
beneficial for the whole digestive
system as well as central nervous system
fasting helps in removing the toxins
from the body fasting increases the
immunity of the body fasting also
reverses the aging process it increases
the longevity lifespan of a human being
fasting also helps in creation of more
of te cells which are killer
cells and fasting as a whole it
rejuvenates and overhuls the complete
body and there are various
diseases which helped when a person fast
for example a person who's suffering
from certain diseases and if a person
fasts it's helpful for him for example
in cardiovascular diseases a person
suffering from athema from arthritis
from digestive disorders if he suffering
from lupus from skin disorders if he
suffering from non-insulin diabetes
there are various the list can go on and
go on and it is even helpful in removing
a person who's addicted to things which
are Haram and even medically they aren
good for example smoking or person who
is an alcoholic or a person who a chain
smoker fasting helps him in Breaking
this wrong habit an addiction let's move
on to the next
question relates to the science behind
the benefits of fasting there are some
people and I want to know whether
they're right or not who say that
fasting actually has some harmful
effects on a person psychological social
physical Etc is that correct several
researches have been done by many
scientists as far as fasting is
concerned and what effect does it have
in various aspects of the human
body and scientists will tell us that
when a person takes in food it increases
the metabolism of the
body when the food intake is reduced or
when a person
fast the body metabolism rate goes down
by about
22% and if you fast continuously for
several days or for a month then this
stabilizes at a lower rate so the body
metabolism rate is reduced by
fasting further there research done on
various groups of male and female
Muslims who had fasted and it showed
that there was a slight reduction in the
body
weight but there was an increase in the
glucose level
as far as all the other things are
concerned it remained constant whether
it was the testosterone of the CTIC cell
whether it was sodium potassium Ura
whether it was cholesterol whether it
was HDL high density lipoprotein whether
it was LDL low density lipoprotein
whether it was TG the triglyceride all
these the body level remain the same the
fasting did not have any effect on them
except it increased the glucose re and
there was a slight reduction in weight
when another research was conducted in
Iran where some men fasted for about 17
hours for about 30 days in the month of
Ramadan it showed that it had no
effect on the male reproductive hormone
on the
testosterone and it had no effect on the
hpta as well as on the thyroid hormones
there were research is conducted there
was also a research there was a study
made which was called as increase in
oxidation in the month of Ramadan on
healthy woman a way from maintaining the
weight weight maintenance and it showed
that during fasting there was no change
as far as the physiology of the body was
concerned the weight was same and all
the functions were the same fasting
increases the fat oxidation and
decreases the carbohydrate
oxidation and we have to realize realiz
that we have to let the Physicians of
the Western World they should know that
they should not the levels of B Rubin
and
glucose while
fasting there further studies
conducted that fasting
increases the mucosa developed
boside cell responsiveness but it not
show a change in the bosy responsiveness
of the rheumat arthritis and the health
volunteers but in fasting it increase
the longevity of the life increases
lifespan many researches conduct in
animals it increases lifespan further
research was conducted on the lactating
woman when they fasted the fasting did
not increase or decrease there was no
change in the milk volume as well as the
content of the milk the glucose level
was the same the fat concentration was
the same the
lactose content was the same there was
no change per se as far as the lactating
M were concerned there were research is
done regarding fasting effect on
menstruating women as well as the
reproductive
cycle and when the research was done
there was no change whatsoever there
wasn't any change in the men cycle in
fasting or there was no negative effect
no positive effect so it is wrong to to
say that fasting has a ill effect there
are many benefits which we discussed
earlier but there are certain positive
points that fasting has
helped in certain diseases for example
Rheumatic arthritis osteoarthritis it
helps and what we realized that when
researches were done that on
animals when they are sick they don't
prefer having any food same thing with
the children when children get sick they
don't prefer having food it is the
family members who force them to have
food and researchers has shown that when
food is taken when a person is sick it
prevents him from getting well early it
hampers the immune system so when a
person fasts when he seriously ill it
helps him to recover faster that the
reason now we find that there are many
treatments which include fasting for
various diseases which are followed by
the Western world because when a person
fast
his body gets rest and the toxins are
removed from the body so it helps him to
recover
faster and fasting is also good to
change the behavior pattern and if a
person is addicted or a person is
alcoholic as I mentioned earlier or is a
chain smoker if he fast it's a good
point that he can stop it throughout his
life and people who have uated to things
like tea coffee junk food when they fast
and they stay away from it when they
taste buds they don't have for the full
month The Taste bus don't crave for that
and when they have healthy food they
start liking it so it's a good time to
stay away from junk food if you can do
it for one month you can do it
throughout your
life yes and there are certain
diseases for example insulin dependent
diabetes a person who's suffering from
insulin dependent diabetes he should not
fast because he has ketosis normally the
ketones are used as a source of energy
but if a person has insulin dependent
diabetes he's unable to use this so
therefore person who has insulin
dependent diabetes he should not fast
but naturally if he takes insulin and
fast and with the medical advice it's
fine but the other type of Diabetes
which is more common noninsulin
dependent diabetes fasting is helpful
for that
and as I mentioned earlier it's helpful
in various diseases
like cardiovascular disease asema
arthritis digestive tract diseases in
lupus and skin disease you can name a
list of diseases in which fasting is of
great
benefit brothers and sisters inshallah
we'll meet soon after this short
break is radan
[Music]
dear brothers and sisters in Islam and
Humanity asalamu alaykum welcome back to
the show Ramadan date with Dr zakya I'm
your host Yousef Chambers and today we
are discussing the benefits of
fasting
alaykum Dr Zak here I think it would be
really interesting to know I mean this
research has it been done by Muslims
non-muslims these researches have been
done by both Muslims and non-muslims and
there are hundreds of non-muslim
scientists who have done research on
fasting so it's not only the Muslims
more of the non-muslims do research on
fasting but there are even Muslims for
example if you read the book fasting a
way of life by alen cot he
writes that
fasting is altogether
it gives
rest to the digestive tract as well as
the central nervous system for the whole
body and he's a non-muslim there was a
research by Indian doctor by the name of
Dr Shanti rangwani and she says that
when a person
fast there's no intake of food so the
toxins are created by the food that you
eat so no new toxin is created and
whatever toxin is there Pres present in
the body from before it gets excreted
from the body so fasting is a very good
method of excreting all the toxins from
the body and it purifies the body system
by non-muslim the research done even
Muslim the research done by Dr Salan in
the university hospital in Amman in
Jordan and he did a research on a group
of men and women there were 42 men and
women and the research was done that
they fasted and the changes in the body
was
noted and they found out that there was
a slight reduction in
weight and there was an increase in the
glucose level but as far as the other
components are concerned testosterone
cortisol sodium potassium UA all of them
remained the same there's no change as
per in the body cont except the glucose
level increase and the reduction in the
weight of the human being there were
several researches done by
non-muslims there was a group of
non-muslim scientist who did research in
Africa in areas where they were famine
and they realized that people when they
research that people who were starving
because of famine and they lived in the
same refugee camp some people who had
food and some people who were starving
but those who are starving they had less
chances of having
tuberculosis as well as malaria so fast
ing increase the defense mechanism
against tuberculos and malaria so it's
Allah's Mercy alhamdulillah can you
believe because they were starving it
prevented them from having tuberculosis
as well as malaria
allahar the researches done by
non-muslims we show that fasting
increases the longevity increase
lifespan and it has a reversal on the
aging
process there was a research done by a
Muslim Scientist by the name name of
drak kandel in the Howard
University Muslim but in a non-muslim
country non-muslim University and he did
a research on patient suffering from
cancer and he tried to find out what way
do the cells
function especially the killer cells
which attacked the cancer cells and he
did accounting just before they started
fasting and then he again did accounting
on the 2 day of Ramadan then 28th day of
Ramadan and he found that there was a
marked difference after 21 days and 28
days the number of cells the killer
cells they increased and these cells
they attack the cancer
cells and it shows that even the
immunity increased the defense mechanism
of the human being because of fasting it
increased and there was another research
again done in the same patients and it
found out that the tea
cells which are normally required for
the defense immunity of the human being
they increase to gate level and tea
cells are mainly responsible when anyone
has a disease they are mainly the
soldiers or they are called Major
General of the army that you have they
are the te cells and they go and they
see to it any disease is there it goes
and try and destroy the disease and Aid
is the disease which mainly attacks
these te cells
therefore it's known as acquired immune
deficiency syndrome so when you fast
these cells increase and the immunity of
the human beings increase i' would like
to mention one more research done by a
European non-muslim by the name of
Dr Jeffrey and what he says that fasting
is not only done by human
beings fasting is even done by the
animals and the plants and and give the
example the animals that live in cold
countries during heavy
snowfalls they stay
separately and they don't eat and they
go in
hibernation and there are examples of
animals like frog which go in
hibernation and here they don't eat
their fast and he gave the example in
his book that even the trees in winter
when they don't get water they're
fasting but the moment
later when spring comes you'll find that
the tree is filled up with colorful
leaves with flowers with
fruits and he suggested that every human
being every year should at least fast
for 40
days and we know that it's f for every
Muslim to fast in the month of Ramadan
there approximately 30 days and further
if you keep the six days of fasting in
shaal that makes it 36 days so Allah
subhana tala and our Prophet has already
given us this guidance which the
non-muslim European has given us
recently so the many research in
non-muslims on fasting and it's very
beneficial for the human body Dr Zakia
most of the research that you've
mentioned I suspect a lot of the other
research we haven't had time to mention
today um was done relatively
recently um was this knowledge this
scientific knowledge available for the
Muslims in
history as far as the earlier Muslims
are
concerned some of the facts were known
some were not known not in the same way
as we have come to know by thearch today
and I'll give you the reason why later
the main question is concerned that were
they aware about these aspects of
fasting in a different way may not be
the same way as we know today that
reminds me I read a book by m Abul
Hassan AR
where
abwi he writes in his
book and he gives an incidents at the
time of khalifah harun Rashid and there
he gives a dialogue between the
Christian
physician of khif harun Rashid and a
Muslim by the name of Ali bin Hussein
bin
wed and this Christian physician of khif
harun Rashid he says
that the Quran is considered to be a
book of
Sciences and we know that two types of
Sciences science of the body science of
the Soul so what does your Quran speak
about medical
science so Ali Hussein B he said that
Allah subhah wa ta'ala in half a verse
of the Quran he combines both these
Sciences when he says in Sur chapter
number seven verse number 31 eat and
drink but do not waste in excess for
Allah subh tala likes not the people who
waste then the Christian Scientist says
but what did your Prophet Muhammad
sallam say about
medicine so he said that he's mentioned
that the stomach is the main house of
diseases and
prevention is the best thing for ailment
in provision is better than cure and as
I mentioned our beloved Prophet said
it's mentioned
in MA volume number four Hadith number
3349 the prophet said the son of Adam
does not fill a vessel more worse more
evil than the stomach a few muscles are
sufficient to keep him on his
feet if he has to eat
more one3 of the stomach can be food one
third drink and one third should be for
his
breath so then that Christian physician
said that
means when you had the guidance of your
Allah and Prophet Muhammad we did not
require Jalin Jalin he was a very famous
non-muslim physician of that time so
what the prophet and Allah say is a
telegraphic message which we have done
research today but the prophet also
already has given a nutshell the message
before and in that same
book he mentions and he gives the
example of another non-muslim scientist
who's an American he says that every
human being whether poor or Rich he
should fast for some days every year it
will keep him healthy and then he says
that Islam is the best religion which
has made it compulsory on his followers
to fast
and he said that Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him was the best
physician who has prescribed fasting and
he said that there's no better healthy
way than fasting and after that t in
which you have to do some exercise going
to him which helps in digestion so if
you realize that the non-muslim
appreciated the religion of Islam after
doing
research though many of the Muslims are
aware about the medical benefits of
fasting but we Muslims we don't fast for
these medical benefits we fast for sake
of Allah subhana tala for the pleasure
of Allah subhana tala we don't fast for
the medical benefits these medical
benefits are anary yeah or they may be
the maybe sweet dishes maybe the dessert
our main Biryani our main meal course is
for pleasure of Allah subhana tala which
we discussed in the objective of fasting
we don't fast for medical benefits even
if the medical benefits were not there
we Muslim would have for Allah subhana
tala but as what do we do for Allah
subhana tala Allah gives us back in
return so all the acts that we do it
actually benefits Us in various ways in
this world as well as in but we Muslims
don't fast for these medical benefits
these are just bonuses that we get
irrespective whether we get or not yet
we fast for the S of Allah yeah that's
good so when you listen to The
Commandments of Allah subhana wa tala
wasallam look at his life and Implement
those things immediately you get some
benefit in this world Subhan
Allah dear brothers and sisters
inshallah we'll meet soon after the
short
break is
Ramadan dear brothers and sisters and
Islam and Humanity asalamu alaykum
welcome back to the show r date with Dr
zakya I'm your host Yousef Chambers and
today we are discussing the benefits of
fasting
alaykum Dr Zak may Allah give us great
benefits through the fasting we've
discussed so many benefits there's so
many to discuss Dr Zakia I think we
could have three programs on this just
on this subject alone but
alas we can't spend that much more time
in the interview stage because it's come
to an end and we need now to take some
questions from the audience from the
people watching peace TV so let's move
on
now the first question we have from one
of our viewers
is many Muslims fast during the day but
overeat in the
nighttime during the month of
Ramadan many eat more food in the month
of Ramadan during the nights than they
do during non Ramadan
time will they be in a position to
derive the medical benefits that the
person who doesn't eat too much will
get as far as deriving the medical
benefits those people who overit in the
night and we know there are many Muslims
un fortunately who eat a lot during ifar
they eat in excess and many of them keep
on eating most part of the night and
then they fast this is against the
command of Allah tala Allah says in
Surah chapter number 7 verse number 31
eat and drink but waste not by excess
Allah subhana wa ta'ala does not like
the wasters here we know people buy food
they have parties where they make a
variety of dishes it goes in waste and
loss of flot of
money which can benefit the poor
people surely this is not the way of
Islam and as I mentioned earlier beloved
Prophet M wasallam it's mentioned in the
Hadith of ma volume number four Hadith
number 3349 that the son of Adam does
not fill a vessel more worse than the
stomach few mus are sufficient to keep
him on his feet if he wants to eat more
you should divide the stomach in three
parts one3 for food one3 for drink and
one3 for his breath or 1/3 for air based
on this but natural overeating is
against the Sunnah against the
Commandment of Allah subhana tala and
even he will not get the benefit of
fasting fasting means a person abstains
from food and then has normal doesn't
overit so most of the benefits that are
mentioned in the medical benefits most
of them he will not get some he may get
sometimes if he oits excessively it may
cause a dam to health it's like I give
the example in the last episode person
eats then he puts his finger in the
throat and wets out so the food he eats
will not make him healthy so here the
fasting will not benefit if he overeats
it goes against the principle of
fasting good I think that's a very uh
concise answer and that's what we need
there lots of questions to get through
Dr Zakia second question from one of our
viewers again if a Muslim
fast with an intention of reducing his
or her
weight uh or
dieting will he get the reward of
fasting he or she if you're talking
about reward in general Islamic they're
talking about jna forgiveness Etc our
beloved Prophet said in book of fasting
Hadith number
2331 that there's no fast for a person
who does not intend to
fast the night before intention is a
must intention means for the sake of
Allah subhana tala for the pleasure of
Allah a person who doesn't have this
intention surely he will not get the
religious benefits he will not get the
spiritual benefits the reason why we
fast that is tawa what we discussed in
the last episode as far as the other
medical benefits the person does for
dieting or if he does for weight loss he
may get those benefits like there are
people who fast maybe for political
reason people do Hunger Strike
people they fast for a
pressure some people fast as you
mentioned for weight loss for dieting so
that part of the medical benefit they
may get but not the benefit completely
of Islam and as Allah says in the Quran
in Surah HUD chapter number 11 verse
number 15 16 anyone who does any Deeds
for this world Allah will sure give him
the reward without diminishing for this
world but he will have no reward in the
Hereafter except for Hellfire and he's
really the person who does such deed is
really misguided so fasting only for
weight loss dieting is just it is
Pennywise pound foolish what have
realized that we have to mainly fast for
the sake of Allah subhana tala then we
get the overall
benefit okay I prefer to be a little bit
fat and then uh but go to paradise
actually actually wouldn't you okay no
you can become thin and yet go to
paradise if you fast the complete right
like the of the Prophet abely wasn't fat
alhamdulillah yes I get your point Dr
Zaki next question the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam we've heard
in previous uh episodes of the series um
used to break fast with the dates and
it's therefore highly recommended to
break fast with the date um can you
inform us about the medical benefits of
date
dates is a wholesome
food dates contain high level of
carbohydrates 44 to 88% it has a low fat
content2 to
.5% there are about 15 minerals and
salts in dates about six vitamins the
protein level is 2.3 to 5.6% it has a
high fiber
content 6. 4 to
11.5% depending upon the different types
of dates and if you realize that because
of the high carbohydrate content it is a
very good source of energy the moment
you have date immediately it gives you
energy it is far better than any other
whether you have the glucose powder Etc
the date gives instant energy and a
person can survive only on dates and
water for days and months together and
our Prophet m am there used to be no
food for days and weeks together in his
house and he used to survive only on
date and water sometime on date and
camel milk so date is wholesome
food the fat content it doesn't increase
the weight hardly any so there's no risk
a person who you know afraid oh the
weight will increase that's not there as
far
as the minerals are concerned it
contains about 15 different minerals it
even contains
fluide which prevents the to Decay it
contains
selenium which fights against cancer and
increases the immune system of the human
body it contains about six vitamins
though to a
less degree less contain it contains
vitamin C vitamin B1 vitamin B2 nasin it
contains vitamin A it has proteins which
have 23 different amino acids and this
fruit date has amino acids which are not
contained in other fruits which normally
people have it's not present in apple
oranges banana but is there in the date
and date also has very high content of
fiber it's a fibrous diet so it goods
for digestion when you have date the
digestion gets cleared it can cure
constipation and Di system is clear it
has various benefits and it is a
wholesome
food and and we realize that
alhamdulillah in the last 40 years the
production of date has increased by 2.9
times and the population of the world
has increased twice so the dead
population is much more than the
population of the human beings because
it's very wholesome food and instant
energy next question somebody wants to
know how does fasting differ from
anorexia anorexia by definition means
loss of appetite it's a medical word
used for loss of appetite and many of
time this happens in certain
people those who dieting it's common in
young
ladies it's a sort of a disease that
those who died they abstain from food
and then that becomes the habit and they
don't want to have anything and sometime
they may go into anorexia nervosa that
psychological disorder that they fear
eating thinking that if they eat they
will increase weight and that becom a
psychological
disorder so anorexia is nothing but loss
of appetite and dieting is not preferred
because most of the people that diet the
moment they come off the diet they
either going to anorexia nervosa that's
psychological disorder which I mentioned
which they fear eating anything increase
of weight and then they lose weight the
health goes down or they go into a binge
of overa buic you know they eat
excessive food and there were several
researches conducted on this including
in Michigan in 1995
where about 557 young
ladies enrolled in the University out of
which 86% were dieting only
2% of them they used to eat excessively
but in 6 months time 19% added into the
bomic category they start eating more
because the moment you stop
dieting you tend to eat excessively and
become more fat or you go vice versa on
the other side Andro nervosa where you
don't eat at all and that damages your
body Subhan Allah well you to help us
not to get into
that next question what is the
scientific difference between fasting
and
salvation fasting scientifically
starts somewhere close to within 12
hours to up to 24
hours and when the carbohydrate reserves
of the body are used as a source of
energy it's called as
fasting
moment it
starts after maybe a few hours initially
the food is utilized when the food
intake reduces and when the carbohydrate
reserves of the body is used for energy
source it's called as fasting but
after the carbohydrate Source in the
body
depletes gets completely used up then
the protein is used when protein is used
as a source of energy it's called a
starvation then you find that the muscle
mass keeps on reducing the person
becomes thin and it becomes unhealthy
scientifically when the carbohydrate
Source gets depleted and the protein
source is used it's called a starvation
which is not good for the body at all
fasting is healthy for the body
starvation is
unhealthy well ja once again Dr Zak here
and we've heard many benefits of fasting
tonight and I hope and I pray Allah
subhana wa tala enables us to take those
benefits those benefits and the
instructions you've given tonight and
utilize them during this wonderful month
of
fasting dear brothers and sisters
may Allah subhana wa ta'ala
bestow
benefits for the whole of this month
regarding the fasting especially as now
you've got no excuse because you've
heard all the medical rais on detras and
all the spiritual religious physical
psychological medical reasons you've got
absolutely no excuse so please take
benefit of Dr Zaki night
advice in this show and in the preceding
shows and we will join you same time
tomorrow and we will be discussing
Ramadan the month of repentance